here at home safety is the top priority
is Lunar New Year celebrations continue
in the valley Madison Kimbrough is at
the Chinatown Plaza tonight with more on
the changes
yeah there were numerous events planned
across the valley including this two-day
event that took place here in Chinatown
it was the Chinatown Plaza hosted by
aapi Chamber of Commerce at the event
which was supposed to go on till 8 pm
tonight had to close early due to strong
winds but the real focus of today was
making sure everyone stayed safe while
celebrating the Chinese New Year
here we've always had a great
relationship with Metro and I'm so glad
it's morning that the first call that I
had was from the captain of the Spring
Valley command assuring us that they'll
be here today and help the community be
safe
the event like I mentioned it is in its
second day was held in the parking lot
area of Chinatown Plaza and had a
plethora of vendors selling food along
with music and performers who took to
the stage now for those who may not know
the Lunar New Year celebrations
typically last for 15 days and this year
it will conclude on February 5th again
this event ended early because of the
strong winds but of course if you're
still wanting to celebrate tonight we
know that Downtown Summerlin is hosting
their parade that started at 5 pm and
will go on throughout the evening
reporting in Chinatown Madison Kimber 8
News Now